but
another way to say that is
wisdom is uh constantly
expanding and evolving set of metrics
but so which means there is something in
you that is recognizing a new metric
that's important that isn't part of that
metric set
so there's a certain kind of connection
discernment
yeah awareness and this is this
iterative game theory
there's the girdles and completeness
theorem right which is if the system if
the set of things is consistent it won't
be complete so we're going to keep
adding to it which is
why we're saying earlier i don't think
it's not beautiful
and especially if you were just saying
one of the metrics you want to optimize
for at the individual level is becoming
right they were becoming more well
that's then becomes true for the
civilization and our metric sets as well
and our definition of how to think about
a meaningful life in a meaningful
civilization
i can tell you what some of my favorite
metrics are what's that
uh well love is obviously not a metric
it's like you can bench
yeah it's a good metric yeah i want to
optimize that across the entire
population starting with infants
um so
in the same way that love isn't a metric
but you could make metrics that look at
certain parts of it this thing i'm about
to say isn't a metric but it's a it's a
consideration
because i thought about this a lot i i
don't think there is a metric a right
one
um i think that every metric by itself
without this thing we talked about of
the continuous improvement becomes a
paperclip maximizer
i think that's why what the idea of
false idol
means in terms of the model of reality
not being reality then my sacred
relationship is to reality
itself which also binds me to the
unknown forever to the known but also to
the unknown and there's a sense of
sacredness connected to the unknown that
creates an epistemic humility that is
always seeking not just to optimize the
thing i know but to learn new stuff
and to be open to perceive reality
directly so my model never becomes
sacred my model is useful
the model can't be the false idle
correct yeah
and this is why the first verse of the
tao te ching is the dao that is nameable
is not the eternal dao
the naming then can become the source of
the ten thousand things that if you get
too carried away with it can actually
obscure you from paying attention to
reality beyond in
the models it sounds a lot a lot like
steven wolfram but in a different
language much more poetic
i can imagine that no i'm referring i'm
joking
but there's echoes of cellular automata
which you can't name
you can't construct a good model
cellular automata
you can only watch in awe i apologize
i'm distracting your train of thought
horribly and miserably
making it by the way something robots
aren't good at
in uh dealing with the uncertainty of
uneven ground
you've been okay so far you've been
doing wonderfully so what's your
favorite metrics
okay so i know you're not wrong so i
have a fascinatory test so one metric
and there are problems with this but one
metric that i like to just as a thought
experiment to consider
is because you're actually asking
work i mean i know you ask your guests
about the meaning of life because
ultimately when you're design when
you're saying what is a desirable
civilization you can't answer that
without answering
what is a meaningful human life and to
say what is a good civilization because
it's going to be in relationship to that
right um
and then you have whatever your answer
is how do you know what is the
what is the epistemic basis for for
postulating that
um there's also a whole other reason for
asking that question i don't
i mean but that doesn't even apply to
you whatsoever
which is it's interesting how few people
have been
asked questions like it
we we we joke about these questions is
silly
right it's it's funny to watch a person
and if i was more of an i would
really stick on that question right
it's a silly question in some sense but
like we haven't really considered
what it means just a more concrete
version of that question is
what is what is a better world what is
the kind of world we're trying to create
think well have you really thought i'll
give you some
kind of simple answers to that that are
meaningful to me
but let me do the societal indices first
because they're fun yes
we should take a note of this meaningful
thing because it's important to come
back to
um are you reminding me to ask you about
the meaning of life noted
let me jot that down yeah so
um well because i think i stopped
tracking it like 25 open threads
um okay let it all burn
one index that i find very
interesting is the inverse correlation
of addiction within the society
the more a society produces addiction
within the people
in it the less healthy i think the
society is
as a pretty fundamental metric and so
the more the individuals feel that there
are less
compulsive things in
compelling them to behave in ways that
are destructive to their own values
uh and in so far as a civilization is
conditioning and influencing the
individuals within it
the inverse of addiction uh
yeah compulsive behavior that is
destructive towards things that we value
yeah i think that's a very interesting
one that's a really interesting one yeah
and this is then also where comfort
and addiction start to get very close
and the ability
to go in the other direction from
addiction is the ability to be exposed
to hypernormal stimuli and not
go down the path of desensitizing to
other stimuli and needing that
hypernormal stimuli
which does involve a kind of hormesis so
i do think the civilization of the
future has to create
something like ritualized discomfort
and um
virtualized discomfort yeah i think
that's what the sweat lodge
and the vision quest and the solo
journey and the ayahuasca journey and
the sundance were
i think it's even a big part of what
yoga asana was
is to make beings that are resilient and
strong they have to overcome some things
to make beings that can control their
own mind and fear they have to face some
fears
but we don't want to put everybody in
war or real trauma
and yet we can see that the most
up people we know
had childhoods of a lot of trauma but
some of the most incredible people we
know had childhoods have a lot of trauma
whether or not they happen to make it
through and overcome that or not
so how do we get the benefits of the
stealing of character and the resilience
and the whatever that happened from the
difficulty without traumatizing people
a certain kind of ritualized discomfort
that not only has us overcome something
by ourselves but overcome it together
with each other where nobody bails when
it gets hard because the other people
are there so it's both
a resilience of the individuals and the
resilience of the bonding
so i think we'll keep getting more and
more comfortable stuff but we have to
also
develop resilience in the presence of
that
for the anti-addiction direction and the
fullness of character
and the trustworthiness to others so you
have to be
uh consistently injecting discomfort
into the system ritualize
i mean this sounds like uh you have to
imagine sisyphus happy
you have to uh imagine sisyphus with his
rock
optimally resilient from a metrics
perspective
in society so we we want
we want to constantly be throwing rocks
at ourselves
not constantly uh you didn't have to
frequently
um periodically periodically and there's
different levels of intensity different
periodicities now i do not think this
should be imposed by states i think it
should emerge from cultures
and i think the cultures are developing
people that understand the value of it
so the people
so there is both a cultural cohesion to
it but there's also a voluntarism
because the people value
the thing that is being developed they
understand it and that's what conditions
with conditioning
it's conditioning some of these some of
these values and
conditioning is a bad word because we
like our idea of sovereignty but when we
recognize
the language that we speak and the words
that we think and in the
in the patterns of thought built into
that language and the aesthetics that we
like and so much
is conditioned in us just based on where
we're born you can't not condition
people so all you can do is take more
responsibility for what the conditioning
factors are and then you have to think
about this question of what is a
meaningful human life because we're
unlike the other animals born into
environment that they're genetically
adapted for we're building new
environments that we were
not adapted for and then we're becoming
affected by those so then we have to say
well what kinds of environments digital
environments physical environments
social environments
would we want to create that would
develop the
healthiest happiest most moral noble
meaningful people
and what are even those sets of things
that matter so you end up getting
deep existential consideration at the
heart of civilization design when you
start to realize how powerful we're
becoming
and how much what we're building it in
service towards matters
before i pull it i think three threads
you just laid down
uh is there another metric index that
you're interested in i'll tell you one
more that i really like
there's a there's a number but one then
the next one that comes to mind is
i have to make a very quick model uh
healthy human bonding say we were in a
travel type setting
my positive emotional states in your
positive emotional states
would most the time be correlated your
negative emotional states in mine
and so you start laughing i start
laughing you start crying my eyes might
tear up
and we would call that the
compassion compersion axis i would this
is
a model i find useful so compassion is
when you're feeling something negative i
feel
some pain i feel some empathy something
in relationship compersion is when you
do well i'm stoked for you
right like i actually feel happiness i
like conversion
yeah the fact that it's such a uncommon
word in english is actually a problem
culturally um because i feel that often
and i think that's a really good feeling
to feel
and maximize for actually that's
actually the metric i'm going to say oh
wow
is the compassion compersion access is
the thing i would optimize for
now there is a state where my
emotional states in your emotional
states are just totally decoupled
and that is like sociopathy i don't want
to hurt you but i don't
care if i do or for you to do well or
whatever but there's a worse state and
it's extremely common which is where
they're inversely coupled
where my positive emotions correspond to
your negative ones and vice versa
and that is the i i would call it the
jealousy sadism axis
the jealousy axis is when you're doing
really well i feel something bad
i feel taken away from less than upset
envious whatever and
that's so common
but i think of it as kind of a low-grade
psychopathology
that we've just normalized the idea that
i'm actually
upset at the happiness or fulfillment or
success of another is like a profoundly
up thing
no we shouldn't shame it and repress it
so it gets worse we should study it
where does it come from and it comes
from our own insecurities and stuff
and but then the next part that
everybody knows is really up
is just on the same axis it's the same
inverted which is
so the jealousy or the envy is the i
feel badly when
you're doing well the sadism side is i
actually feel good when you lose
or when you're in pain i feel some
happiness that's associated you can see
when someone feels jealous
sometimes they feel jealous with a
partner and then they feel
they want that partner to get it revenge
comes up or something
so sadism is really like jealousy is one
step on the path
to sadism from the healthy compassion
conversion access so
i would like to see a society that is
inversely
that is conditioning sadism and jealousy
inversely right the the lower that
amount and the more the compassion
conversion and if i had to summarize
that very simply i'd say it would
optimize for conversion
which is because notice that's not just
saying love
for you where i might be
self-sacrificing and miserable
and i love people but i kill myself
which i don't think anybody thinks is a
great idea or happiness where i might be
sociopathically happy where i'm
causing problems all over the place or
even sadistically happy
but it's a coupling right that i'm
actually feeling happiness in
relationship to yours and even in causal
relationship where i
my own agentic desire to get happier
wants to support you too
that's actually speaking of another
pickup line uh
that's quite honestly what i this is a
guy who's single this is
this is gonna come out very ridiculous
because it's like oh yeah where's your
girlfriend bro
but that's what i look for in a
relationship
because it's like it's so much it's so
it's such an amazing life where you
actually get
joy from another person's success and
they get joy from your success
and then it becomes like you don't
actually need to succeed much
for that to have a like a a a
like a cycle of just like happiness that
just increases like
exponentially it's weird so like just be
just enjoying the the happiness of
others the success of others
so this this is like the uh let's call
this because the first person that
drilled this into my head is rogan
joe rogan he was the embodiment of that
because i saw somebody who's uh
successful rich
and non-stop truly i mean you could tell
when somebody's full of
somebody's not really genuinely enjoying
the success of his friends
that that was weird to me that was
interesting and i mean the way you're
kind of
speaking to it the reason joe stood out
to me
is i guess i haven't witnessed genuine
expression of that often in this culture
of just real joy for others
i mean part of that has to do there
hasn't been many channels where you can
watch or listen to people being their
authentic cells so i'm sure there's a
bunch of people who live life
with compersion they probably don't seek
public attention also but the
that that was yeah if if there was any
word that could express
what what i've learned from john white
he's been a a really inspiring figure
is that compersion and i wish our world
was uh had a lot more of that
because then it i mean my own
sorry to go to small tangent but like
you're speaking how society should
function
but i feel like if you optimize for that
metric in your own personal life
you're going to live a truly fulfilling
life
i don't know what the right word to use
but that's a really good way to live
life you will also
learn what gets in the way of it
and how to work with it that if you
wanted to help try to build systems at
scale or apply facebook or exponential
technologies to do that you would have
more actual depth of real knowledge of
what that takes
and this is you know as you mentioned
that there's this virtuous cycle
between when you get stoked on other
people doing well and then they have a
similar
relationship to you and everyone is in
the process of building each other up
and this is what i would say the healthy
version of competition is
versus the unhealthy version the healthy
version right the
the root i believe it's a latin word
that means to strive together
and it's that impulse of becoming where
i want to become more but i recognize
that there's actually a
hormesis there's a challenge that is
needed for me to be able to do that
but that means that yes there's an
impulse where i'm trying to get ahead
maybe i'm even trying to win but i
actually want a good opponent
and i want them to get ahead too because
that is where my ongoing becoming
happens and the win
itself will get boring very quickly the
ongoing becoming is where there's
aliveness and for the ongoing becoming
they need to have it too and that's the
stride together the
so in the healthy competition i'm stoked
when they're doing really well
because my becoming is supported by it
you